اصيب ثلاثه اسرائيليين جراح احدهم خطر في
قصف تبنته فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
واعتبرته ردا اوليا على استشهاد الاسير
خضر عدنان في سجون الاحتلال بعد اضرابه عن
الطعام لنحو ثلاثه اشهر وقانت السلطه
والفصائل الفلسطينيه ما سمته اغتيال
اسرائيل للشهيد عدنان بينما وجه وزير
الامن القومي بعدم التساهل مع الاسرى
الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الظروف التي يعيشها
الاف الاسرى الفلسطينيين في سجون الاحتلال
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان تتاثر بتوجيهات وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي بالتشدد معهم بعد
استشهاد القيادي خطر عدنان وكيف سينعكس
تحرك الاسرى الفلسطينيين ضد سياسه التنكيل
الاسرائيلي بهم على المشهد الفلسطيني وعلى
مواقف فصائل المقاومه وما خيارات السلطه
الفلسطينيه ازاءه وكيف نقيم المواقف
الامريكيه والدوليه تجاه تصعيد اسرائيل ضد
الفلسطينيين بمن فيهم الاسرى في ظل حديث
واشنطن المستمر عن سعيها لتثبيت الاستقرار
في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
فيما اعتبرته ردا اوليا على استشهاد
الاسير خضر عدنان في سجون الاحتلال تبنت
غرفه عمليات فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
المشتركه قصفا صاروخيا على مستوطنات غلاف
غزه اسفر بحسب الاسعاف الاسرائيلي عن
اصابه ثلاثه اسرائيليين في بلده سبيروت
شمال شرقي غزه وصفت جراح احدهم بانها
خطيره الجيش الاسرائيلي قال ان 22 صاروخا
اطلقت من قطاع غزه باتجاه اسرائيل وانه
اعترض اربعه وقصف نقطه رص تابعه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه شرق مدينه غزه واعتبر ذلك ردا
على اطلاق الصواريخ
وكان نادي الاسير الفلسطيني قد اعلن
استشهاد الاسير الشيخ خضر عدنان بعد اضراب
عن الطعام استمر نحو ثلاثه اشهر رفضا
لاعتقاله وقال النادي ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اغتال الشيخ خضر عدنان البالغ
من العمر 44 عاما عن سابق اصراره بينما
اكد محامي الشهيد انه استشهد بسبب اهمال
سجانين وضعه الصحي وان محكمه الاحتلال
رفضت طلب الافراج عنه بكفاله
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من رام
الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي امين عام
المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومن القدس
ايهاب جبارين المحلل السياسي والباحث
المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي دكتور مصطفى
نحو ثلاثه اشهر بقي الاسير الشهيد خضر
عدنان دون طعام وعلى الرغم من ذلك لم
تستجب السلطات الاسرائيليه لطلب اخراجها
بكفاله اي دلالات تعطي هذه الحادثه عن
التوجه الاسرائيلي مع الاسرى بشكل عام ومع
القضيه الفلسطينيه
اولا نحن جميعا نشعر الالم بالم وحزن شديد
الان على فقدان هذا المناضل الباسل البطل
خضر عدنان الذي اشترح ماثر عظيمه هذا هو
الاضراب السادس الذي يخوضه
من اجل حريته ومن اجل كرامته ما قام به
الاحتلال تجاهه عمليه اغتيال بشعه واضحه
كالشمس الهدف من الاغتيال هو كسر اراده
المقاومه لدى الاسرى الفلسطينيين
وفرض الاعتقال الاداري كنمط سائد يجبر فيه
والفلسطينيون على ان يعتقلوا حتى دون ان
يعرفوا باي تهمه ولاي سبب يعني اسفاف كامل
بكل القوانين ليس فقط الدوليه بل المحليه
وبكل اعراف وحقوق الانسان الهدف هدف
الاسرائيليين هو ان يرسل رساله ان اضربتهم
عن الطعام ستموتون وهذا امر في غايه
الخطوره هذا امر يريد ان يكرس حقيقه ان
هناك
معتقلين الان معتقال اداري في سجون
الاحتلال دون ان يتوجه اي تهمه لهم وهذا
يعني البطش والتنكيل بالفلسطينيين كل
فلسطيني اليوم اصبحت حياته مهدده بالخطر
كل فلسطيني معرض للاعتقال دون اي سبب وهذا
هو الهدف الهدف القمع والتنكيل وكسر اراده
الاسرى وهذا لن ينجح طبعا ولكن الهدف
الاخر هو كسر اراده المقاومه دكتور مصطفى
هنالك اسرى في السجون الاسرائيليه لا
مستمرون في اضرابهم عن الطعام اي مصير
سيلقى هؤلاء بتقديرك بعد الذي جرى
هناك خطر حقيقي على حياه هؤلاء الاسرى ما
لم نهب اليوم هبه شعب كامل وواحد موحد لي
من اجل اسنادهم واسناد حقهم في الحريه وقد
ان الاوان فعلا ان يكون هناك نضال ليس فقط
من اجل مبدا الحريه الاسرى والافراج عنهم
من سجون الاحتلال بل ايضا من اجل كسر كل
فكره الاعتقال الاداري وهذا كان الهدف
الرئيسي للمناضل عدنان خمس مرات كسر اراده
الاحتلال واجبره على الافراج عنه عبر هذا
عبر الاضراب عن الطعام وفي هذه المره كما
هو واضح الاحتلال قرر ان يقوم باغتياله
بهذا الشكل البشع نحن نتحدث عن ظاهره
خطيره جدا اليوم حتى نحمي حياه اسرانه
واسيراتنا لابد ان يكون هناك فعل فلسطيني
مقاوم كفاحي مشترك وموحد من اجل ان نكسر
اراده الاحتلال ونكسر هذا القمع الخطير
الذي لا يمكن ان يستمر اريد ان اذكر
منذ عام 67 وحتى اليوم كانت هناك مليون
عمليه اعتقال واسد ضد الفلسطينيين هناك 13
الف حاله اعتقال اداري خلال السنوات
الثمانيه الماضيه هذا امر في غايه الخطوره
ويستدعي اليوم التفافا واسعا حول قضيه
الاسراء الاسير خضر عدنان لم يترك مسيره
واحده لم يشارك فيها لم يترك بيت اسير او
اسير لم يكن فيه لم يترك بيت شهيد الا
وكان فيها هذا المناضل الفذ من حقه علينا
اليوم انه فيه ان وفيه مقابل تضحياته
والوفاء له يكون بامرين الدفاع
ولكن الخيار الى نقطه اريد ان اسمع تعليق
عليها من السيد ايهاب جبارين سيد ايهاب
يعني خمسه اضرابات خاضها الاسير
الشهيد خضر عدنان
وتحقق له ما اراد الا ان اضرابه السادس
ادى الى استشهاده كيف اختلف النهج
الاسرائيلي بين ذلك الوقت واليوم
نعم مساء الخير ورحم الله الشهيد الدكتور
خضر عدنان
بطبيعه الحال يجب ان ننظر ان اسرائيل تنظر
الى كل ما يخص قضيه الاسرى بمحورين او
بنقطه تحول مركزيه وهي نقطه اسرى انفاق
الحريه ما قبلها وما بعدها يعني كل
العمليات التنكيل يمكن القول
وعمليات
الاستنفار بكل ما يخص قضايا الاسرى وحتى
الاعتقالات الامنيه اخذت معيارا مغايرا ما
بعدها قضيه الانفاق وما بعد اسرى الانفاق
هذا الامر هذه النقطه المركزيه الاولى
التي نعتمد عليها بدايه النقطه الثانيه
وكذلك التي لا تقل اهميه هي من يقف بطبيعه
الحال في هذا السلم مصلحه السجون
الاسرائيليه مصلحه ضعيفه نوعا ما فلذلك هي
تقبع بشكل مباشر بكل ما يخص
استراتيجياتها وامنياتها الى الرؤيه
السياسيه لمن يقف في راسها
ان الرؤيه السياسيه هذه المره كانت من حصه
استراتيجياته شعبويه يعني ما قبل ذلك لا
يمكن القول ان نوايا الوزراء السابقون
كانت تختلف ولكن السابقون كان لديهم هنالك
اعتبارات امنيه استراتيجيه اكبر بكثير من
الاعتبارات الشعر الشعبويه التي يعتمد
عليها بين جبير فبالتالي وفق لدينا
المكيالين يمكن القول ان مالت اليه
المواسير الى هذه النقطه المحوريه الاولى
عفوا الى هذه النقطه التي وصلنا اليها
والان وكذلك نقطه مهمه جدا هذا على صعيد
من يقف على راس هذا السلم الهرمي في هذه
الوزاره ولكن وبطبيعه الحال نحن ذكرنا ان
او لا يجب ان نقلل من اهميه من يقف رئاسه
الحكومه يعني اغلب الاضرابات التي خاضها
الدكتور الشهيد خضر عدنان كانت كذلك في
زمن حكومات بين يمين نتنياهو بل كلها
الخمس السابقه كانت في زمن حكومات بنيامين
نتنياهو بين يمين نتنياهو ايضا في هذه
المرحله لديه معايير مغيره حتى الاجراءات
الامنيه الاستراتيجيه كانت تبحث عن تصعيد
لا يمكن القول انها كانت لا كانت لم تكن
تبحث عن هذا التصعيد بل كانت تبحث عن هذا
التصعيد
يعني جصنب
بالضبط ما دلاله عدلك يعني خلال الاسابيع
الاخيره كان هنالك الكثير من التصريحات
رئيس الاركان الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي كان
يصارح ويقول ان نحن جاهزون لعده جبهات
اسرائيل الان في هذه المرحله تبحث بشكل
مباشر عن اليه لاعاده الردع اليه الردع في
هذه المرحله يعني ويمكن القول حتى الردود
الفعل التي خاضتها اسرائيل خلال هذا اليوم
تحديدا يمكن القول انها كانت تبحث عن هذا
التصعيد كانت تبحث عن رؤيه
اسباب تدعها الخوض في تصعيد معين خلال
الايام المقبل لا يمكن القول ان اسرائيل
في هذه المرحله يعني والتي اخذت
استراتيجيه او او بشكل لم يكن لديها هنالك
استراتيجيه للتعامل مع قطاع غزه
استراتيجيه واضحه في كل ما يخص الضفه
الغربيه لكن قطاع غزه هي كانت تعلم ان اي
يعني اغتيال الشهيد خضر عدنان ممكن ان
يؤدي الى استنفار امن بكل ما يخص قطاع غزه
فبالتالي ووفق هذه الدلالات يمكن القولون
حتى اذا المرحله لم يكن لديها استراتيجي
اسرائيل ارادت ان تجس النبض او ان تستدعي
هذا التصعيد تماما كما فعلت مع الجهاد
الاسلامي في شهر اغسطس الماضي هي استدعت
التصعيد امامه على الرغم الحكومه التي
كانت مغايره او كان ما كان يسمى بحكومه
التغيير وفق الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه
الاخرى ولكن هذه المره هي نادت هذا
التصعيد واستدعت هذا التصعيد عبر اغتيال
الشهيد وهنا ذلك نقطه مهمه جدا كذلك يجب
ان تذكره ان ربما اسرائيل لم تتوقع ان
تخوض حماس او يعني وهذا يعني يمكن رؤيته
من حتى من من بعض ردود الفعل ان تخوض حماس
هذا
بغرفه يعني غرفه
عمليات مشتركه لكل الفصائل الفلسطينيه
كانت تعتمد اكثر على رد فعل لجهاد
الاسلامي وبذلك تستفرد به بالجهاد
الاسلامي هنا وبهذه النقطه وهي عملت على
ذلك على مدى سنوات اسرائيل ان تستفرض او
ان تفصل ما بين حماس والجهاد الاسلامي هنا
ما حدث اليوم بالنسبه اليها نقطه مغايره
اسرائيل سوف تستدعي رده مغايرا في خلال
الايام
دكتور مصطفى ان ياتي الرد وتحمل المسؤوليه
عن اطلاق الصواريخ من كل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في بيان مشترك يعني ما الذي
يمكن ان نفهمه من هذا البيان المشترك انه
لا يمكن الاستئثار بفصيل دون اخر ان
الفصائل كلها يد واحده اي رساله من جهتها
تحاول الفصائل ايصالها لاسرائيل
بالتاكيد هذا هو رد فلسطيني يقول اننا
موحدون في المقاومه وموحدون في الرد على
جرائم اسرائيل ولن يسمح لاسرائيل مره اخرى
بان تستفرد باي فصيله او اي طرف او اي شخص
وربما بالاضافه الى وحده الفصائل قد نشهد
وحده الساحات مره اخرى
الامر الان في بدايته ونحن نتوقع هجمات
اسرائيليه شرسه وخطيره ايضا على قطاع غزه
هذه الليله وبالتالي يمكن ان ندخل في
دوامه كبيره جدا في مواجهه كبيره جدا تشمل
ليس فقط المناطق الفلسطينيه بالمناطق اخرى
ايضا ولكن دعيني اقول انه التغيير الاساسي
الذي نعيشه اليوم هو بالضبط ما توقعناه
الكثيرون قللوا من اهميه انه في اسرائيل
اليوم ليس فقط حكومه عنصريه متطرفه مثل كل
الحكومات ولكن حكومه فاشيه بالمعنى الحرفي
للكلمه والاعتداء على خضر عدنان واغتيال
خضر عدنان والاعتداء على الاسرى هو جزء من
منظومه تشمل خمسه
الاستيطان المستشري والمتوحش الى درجه
الاعلان عن سبعين مستوطنه جديده ولا احد
يتحرك الحديث عمليه القمع والقتل التي
طالت 104 شهداء منذ بدايه هذا العام
الفلسطينيه اضيفي الى ذلك الاعتداءات على
المسجد الاقصى والحرم الابراهيمي في
الخليل والان طبعا الاعتداء على الاسرى
وبعد ذلك طبعا اعتداءات على قطاع غزه هذا
الذي يجري لاننا نواجه حكومه فاشيه عنصريه
مجرمه سكت عليها العالم وعلى جرائمها طيب
دكتور مصطفى تحدثنا عن امكانيه مواجهه
اكبر في ردود الفعل على استشهاد الشيخ خضر
عدنان حملت وزاره الخارجيات الفلسطينيه
حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وادرع وازرعها
المسؤوليه الكامله عن ما سمته جريمه اعدام
الاسير خطر اعدنان وطالبت لجنه التحقيق
الدوليه
الاستثمار في تحقيق الاستمرار في التحقيق
في ملابسات وتفاصيل هذه الجريمه واكدت
انها سترفع ملفها للجنائيه الدوليه اما
حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه التي كان الشهيد
احد قادتها فقد حملت الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المسؤوليه عن استشهاده وتوعدت بعدم مروره
دون رد الناطق باسم الحركه حازم قاسم قال
ان دمع عدنان سيكون وقودا لتصعيد الفعل
الثوري المقاوم ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وان المقاومه ستتصاعد في كل ارجاء فلسطين
ردا على هذه الجريمه
اعود اليك سيد ايهاب جبار سيد ايهاب هل
الامور ستقف عند هذا الحد ما شاهدناه
اليوم من اطلاق صواريخ من قبل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ورده اسرائيل على نقطه محدده
هل ستقف الامور عند هذا الحد ام ممكن ان
تتوسع
نعم يعني هذا باعتبار ان هنالك كذلك
اعتبارات استراتيجيه تاخذها اسرائيل بعين
الاعتبار وهي الابتعاد عن وحده الصف يعني
سالته او كانت هنالك مراهنه وربما هذا ما
ذكره يعني بعض اعضاء الكنيست من اللكود
بان الان
بعيده شهر رمضان بالتالي الان لا يوجد اي
حجج اخرى لعدم التواصل او لعدم الاستفراد
وعلى عدم التوغل اكثر والتصعيد اكثر هذه
يعني بعد التصريحات التي كانت من بعض
اعضاء الحزب حزب الليكودا المحسوبين على
هذه الحكومه فبالتالي يمكن القول ان وفق
هذه الامور وبعيدا عن هذا كله هنالك
مراهنه بانها لن تكون الان وبالذات بعيده
شهر رمضان وحده للصف هذه احدى المراهنات
وهذا ما تحاول اسرائيل ان تقوم به لن اخشى
ما تخشاه اسرائيل في ظل كل هذه المرحله هي
ان تكون هنالك جبهات متعدده على الرغم من
بعض التصريحات التي كانت يعني على لسان
رئيس اركانها وعلى لسانه وزير جيشها كان
هنالك كثير من التصريحات بان جاهزه وهذه
نقطه مهمه جدا تركز عليها اسرائيل
لتصعيد او لحرب متعدد الجبهات ولكنه هنا
تاخذ بعين الاعتبار كذلك الرد الذي كان من
الجبهه الشماليه
ومن جنوب لبنان تحديدا هذا بعين الاعتبار
يمكن القول انها يعني اذا خرجت الامور عن
السيطره في مثل هذه الجبهه الامور بالتالي
يمكن ان تكون اسوا بكثير بالنسبه اليها
سيناريو اسوا بكثير من 2021 وهناك الكثير
من الانتقادات الواسعه بكل ما يخص 2021
بالتالي هذا السيناريو الذي تحاول
الابتعاد عنه والان هي موجوده في مازق
مازق اعاده هيبه الردع التي يعني سقطت
منها على مدى الاشهر الاخيره وهذا يعني
بشهادات من داخل
الاجهزه الامنيه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
وكذلك يعني بعض الانتقادات التي تنسب لهذا
الائتلاف الفاشل الحكومه الحاليه
عن بعض حتى من داخل هذا الائتلاف والنقطه
الثانيه هي بحاجه لتص لكي يعيد هذه
العباره الان هنالك نقطه مهمه جدا يعني
بنهايه المطاف يجب علينا الاعتبار نتنياهو
اعتاد ان يعتاش على تواترات ما رايناه في
الضفه الغربيه خلال شهر مارس وشهر فبراير
هو تواترات وليس بمثابه تصعيدات بل
اغتيالات الوتيره معتدله يمكن القول
السؤال هل سوف يعيد هذه السيناريوهات من
يمين نتنياهو كرد فعل واجراءات امام ما
يجري في داخل
هنا يجب القول انه ما يراهن عليه في هذه
المرحله هو الا يعني ان يقوم بالفض والفصل
ما بين الجهاد الاسلامي وحماس الرد بنظري
كان واضحا وبات واضحا من ردود فعل حماس في
داخل هذه المعركه تحديدا الان هنالك نقطه
مهمه جدا يجب ان نتذكرها ان احد المراهنات
التي كانت واستراتيجيات التي اعتمادها
كذلك بالسابق هي استهداف شخصيات ليست
محسوبه على
الجهاد ولا حماس ربما حتى منفتح او
الشخصيه يعني اغتيال بعض الشهداء من عوين
الاسود هذه الاستاذه كانت في السابق
السؤال هل سوف يعيدها نتنياهو في هذه
دكتور مصطفى
قيام نتنياهو باجتماعا امنيا مع استبعاد
بن كفير اي دلالات يحمل
هذه ليست اول مره يستبعد بن جبير لانه
مجنون ولانه دائما بنغير يخرج ويسرب ما
يجري في هذه الاجتماعات وبالتالي هو
يستثنى من الاجتماعات الامنيه بس انا هذا
لا يقلل من خطوره الوضع الدكتور مصطفى هل
يمكن ان يشكل ذلك
مؤشرا على النهجه التي ستعتمده اسرائيل في
المرحله المقبله باتجاه تصعيد او الاكتفاء
بما جرى اليوم
لا انا اعتقد انهم سيسير نحو التصعيد
والدليل على ذلك انهم سمحوا باغتيال
الشهيد خضر عدنان كان باستطاعه المحكمه
العسكريه ان تحسم الامر وتقرر الافراج عنه
بكفاله ولكن تعمدوا المماطله حتى يستشهد
هذه مساله واضحه النقطه الثانيه يجب ان
نرى في الصوره الداخليه الاسرائيليه امر
مهم جدا الان نتنياهو يواجه ازمه داخليه
كبيره في موضوع التغييرات القضائيه وغيرها
الكنيست الان ستبدا اجتماعاته وهو مقبل
على ازمه داخليه عميقه وكبيره جدا وهو
يعرف انه في استطلاعات الراي يخسر ولا
يستطيع ان يفوز في اي انتخابات قادمه لذلك
هو الان برايي سيلجا الى التصعيد مع
الفلسطينيين وتوتير الاجواء مع
الفلسطينيين للهروب من ازمته الداخليه وفي
محاوله لارضاء الشعبوين في اسرائيل طبعا
والمتطرفين والعنصريين والان تتعالى صيحات
ودعوات الانتقام ضد قطاع غزه هو سيتجه في
اتجاه التصعيد من مشكلته الداخليه ايضا
هذا ايضا احتمال كبير وقائم لكن في نهايه
المطاف علينا ان نتذكر انه مجمل السياسه
الاسرائيليه سياسي عدوانيه اجراميه هدفها
ضم وتهويد الضفه الغربيه بالكامل وهذا ما
يعلنونه لا يخفي يقول بصراحه امام
الفلسطينيين واحد من ثلاثه حلول اما ان
يرحلوا او يرضخوا بشكل كامل للفاشيه
الاسرائيليه او يموتوا كما قال هذه هي
سياسه حكومه اسرائيل هذه التصريحات لم
ينفيها نتنياهو ولا مره واحده على الاطلاق
السؤال ماذا يجب ان نفعل نحن كفلسطينيين
اذا ذلك
ساعود الى خيارات الخيارات الفلسطينيه
ولكن دعني اسهم مع من السيد ايهاب جبارين
فيما يتعلق بالتقييم للموقف الدولي خاصه
ان واشنطن يعني دائما ما تقول انها تسعى
لتهدئه الاوضاع وتثبيتها ما هو تقييمكم
للمواقف الدوليه في هذه المرحله لا سيما
موقف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كذلك حتى بالنسبه للموقف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يمكن القول ان يعني هنالك بعض
الاعتبارات التي فقدت بها يعني ذلك الزخم
للتصريحات الامريكيه وتاثيرها حتى في داخل
هذه المنطقه واخذ هذه الاعتبارات بشكل جدي
حتى من الطرفين كان من الطرف الاسرائيلي
ومن طرف الفلسطيني في نهايه المطاف
الولايات المتحده في هذه المرحله في داخل
مازق يعني لديها هنالك اكثر من حلبه تحاول
ابراز نفسها فيها في داخل عالم متعدد
الاقطاب او يحاول ان يسعى الى مرحله تعدد
الاقطاب تحاول ان تؤكد على مكانتها وبدون
ادنى شكلنا ما يجري في داخل المنطقه يعني
له مكانه مركزيه
لكي تؤكد على هذه المكانه الان او ردود
الفعل الامريكيه بكل ما يجري تحاول ان
تقيم وتؤكد على مسعى الدولتين وما الى ذلك
لكن في نهايه المطاف يعني بعيده عن هذه
الاستنكارات ان كان
الخجوله نوعا ما حتى يمكن القول في هذه
المرحله لان هنالك الكثير من الاعتبارات
يعني اعتباراتها مع اسرائيل هي ليست فقط
امنيه بالامنيه اقتصاديه في نهايه المطاف
هناك الكثير من الاستثمارات الامنيه
الامريكيه في داخل اسرائيل ولذلك يعني نحن
راينا ان على الكثير من النقد الغير مسبوق
للساسه الاسرائيليين للاداره الامريكيه
وعلى ذلك الولايات المتحده حاولت يعني لم
تاخذ ذلك الموقف الحازم
اتجاه اسرائيل
واستراتيجياتها
في تعديل القوانين سيد ايهاب اسمع من
الدكتور مصطفى دكتور مصطفى الخيارات
الفلسطينيه في هذه المرحله على مستوى
السلطه وعلى مستوى فصائل المقاومه
[موسيقى]
نعم قبل ان اجيب على ذلك دعيني اقول انه
السياسه الامريكيه السياسه هزيله ضعيفه
وكل ما يريدونه هم واطراف عديده في
المجتمع الغربي تهدئه على حساب الشعب
الفلسطيني يريد هدوء مع استمرار الاستيطان
هدوء مع استمرار القمع هدوء مع استمرار
الضم والتهويد هدوء بحيث لا يقاوم
الفلسطينيون ما يجري من ضمن واضطهاد لهم
وبالتالي طبعا هذا موقف مشين وغريب انا
اذكر عندما قتلت ثلاث مستعمرات اسرائيليات
قامت الدنيا ولم تقعد الاستنكارات والشجب
والاستنكر ماذا سمعنا بشان خضر عدنان هذا
المناضل الذي استشهد الان وترك وراءه
عائله كبيره لا شيء وبالتالي الازدواجيه
في المعايير ما زالت قائمه وتحكم هذه
السياسه المنحازه لاسرائيل النقطه الثانيه
فيما يتعلق بالخيارات انا برايي السلطه
الفلسطينيه عليها ان توقف المراوحه في
مكانها لم يعد الوقت يسمح ولم يعد الوضع
يسمح اليوم نحن المطالبون بالتوجه نحو
وحده وطنيه حقيقيه والسلطه يجب ان تسير في
هذا الاتجاه ان تدعو الى تشكيل قياده
وطنيه موحده فلسطينيه وان يجري تبني نهج
وطني كفاحي مقاوم بعد ان فشلت الخيرات
الاخرى المراوحه في المكان ستعني مزيد من
الضحايا المراوحه في المكان تعني مزيد من
الخسائر بالتالي الخيار الرئيسي المطلوب
الان التوجه بشكل جذري وشامل نحو
استراتيجيه وطنيه كفاحيه مقاومه نحو
الوحده الوطنيه الفلسطينيه نحو انشاء
قياده وطنيه موحده ودعيني اقول ان الوفاء
لذكرى الشهيد خضر عدنان اليوم تكون بامرين
اولا هب شعبيه واسعه لحمايه الاسرى
والاسيرات والنضال من اجل حريتهم والامر
الاهم النضال المشترك من اجل حمايه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وحق الشعب الفلسطيني
في المقاومه اسرائيل لا تفهم الا لغه
القوه هذا هو الدرس الذي تعلمه الشعب
الفلسطيني الدكتور المصطفى البرغوثي امين
عام الم بادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه كنتمنى
من رام الله شكرا لك ومن القدس ايهاب
جبارين المحلل السياسي والباحث المختص في
الشان الاسرائيلي
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]